Megan Markel Kate Middleton cast as
royal rebels since the former actress
first came on the scene in the fall of
2016
newspaper headlines claimed a rift had
developed between Megan and Kate now
reports suggest that their relationship
could actually be strengthening I am
told that both of them are of making an
effort to get along but let's get to the
bottom of this Kathryn Harry and I are
delighted to be here this morning and
we're particularly happy it's been our
first raw foundation event with Megan
you see one year ago Megan in Kate were
leading totally different lives
the former suits actress was fresh out
of Hollywood and learning how to
navigate her new life as a royal this
has been a big transition period for
Megan Kate on the other hand was
juggling the demands of three young
children including a newborn baby Louie
if you had been the top dog if you had
been the young gorgeous girl that
everyone would be photographing for the
last two or three or four years and all
your works have been highlighted
everything he's done you might be a
little bit put out when this gorgeous
American Hollywood star arrives on the
scene but I think really probably the
truth of the situation is yes there have
been tensions behind the scenes but on
May 6 2009 teen Megan joined Kate in the
rings of motherhood the dream
it's been a special couple of days and
suddenly the sister-in-laws had a lot
more in common I certainly think now
that Archie is here it has probably
really helped to improve the
relationship it's really exciting
I hear that caters made herself
available to Megan if if she needs
advise hates said to her I'm here I'm
here for you the media started focusing
on their seemingly growing bond rather
than rumors of a feud I think the
relationship between the Duchess's is
actually a lot better they seem to be a
genuine warmth between the two of them
and that carriage ride and for trooping
the colour of course two back-to-back
joint appearances didn't hurt first it
was their natural play date at harrion
Williams charity polo match with all
four kiddos in tow we hadn't expected
the Duchess's to turn up with their
children the fact that they did was a
wonderful treat for royal watchers but I
think those candid pictures were quite
deliberately intended to snuff out those
rumours of the feud between the foursome
obviously the two duchesses and being so
close together and and so comfortable in
each other's company yes I think for the
time being and you're not going to read
stories about rumors of a few certainly
Archie has brought them closer and you
know they will be spending you know
certainly certainly spending some time
together over the summer then we saw the
Duchess's looking relaxed and friendly a
few days later at their annual Wimbledon
outings an eyewitness told et it looked
like they were having a fabulous girls
day laughing chatting and enjoying
tennis and according to one report Kate
even rubbed Megan's back to console her
after good friends Serena Williams lost
in the finals what's more it's thought
that Megan in Harry's move out of
Kensington Palace has given the Fab Four
the space they need to reconnect for so
many years Harry was in Williams shadow
it's time now for him toe to break free
to do his own thing with Megan they're
creating their own identities their own
roles within the royal family though it
seems true what they say
distance may in fact make the heart grow
fonder
you
[Music]